est-ce que vous savez ce qui mesure 7 m
qui est plein de microbes et qui sent
pas très bon une chenille à la fête du
camping pendant la canicule les v perdu
c'est vos intestins et ouais dans vos
intestins il y a plein de microbes et
c'est une bonne nouvelle parce que
toutes ces petites bêtes c'est ce qu'on
appelle le microbiote intestinal avant
on appelait ça la flore intestinale mais
définitivement c'est pas des fleurs
c'est des microbes et ce microbiote
intestinal il a des super pouvoirs ah je
sens que je vous accroché là bougez pas
je vais vous raconter tout
ça
notre microbiote intestinal donc il a
des super pouvoirs mais avant de vous
expliquer tout ça je voudrais vous
parler d'un truc cette vidéo elle a été
réalisée en partenariat avec l'Institut
Pasteur l'Institut Pasteur vous
connaissez c'est une fondation qui fait
plein de trucs dans le domaine de la
santé et notamment de la recherche
l'idée c'est de trouver des moyens de
prévenir d'éviter si vous voulez ou de
soigner des maladies et surtout des
maladies infectieuses oui pasteur
c'était son dada les microbes Louis
Pasteur le gars qui a inventé le vaccin
contre entre la rage vous voyez non il a
aussi trouvé un procédé qui empêche le
vin et la bière de se frelater vous
voyez c'était un bon si jamais ça peut
vous convaincre de donner de l'argent
pour la recherche oui parce que
contrairement à ce que beaucoup de gens
pensent l'Institut Pasteur c'est pas un
établissement public financé par l'État
c'est une fondation privée qui doit
faire tourner ses unités de recherche on
parle de 1600 chercheuses et chercheurs
quand même avec tout leur matériel et
cetera et c'est l'argent que donnent des
gens comme vous ou moi qui financent un
tiers de tout ça c'est la raison pour
laquelle ils ont créé le pass don qui se
tient tous les ans pour récolter des
dons et aider les chercheurs pour avoir
plus d'infos et faire un don si vous
voulez aider la recherche vous pouvez
aller sur pasteurdon.fr je vous mets le
lien dans la description de la vidéo bon
mais alors ce microbiote de quoi est-ce
qu'il est vraiment capable c'est quoi
ces super pouvoirs on va déjà répondre à
une première question c'est quoi le
microbiote intestinal exactement là et
oui parce qu'on entend souvent parler du
microbiote mais on sait pas vraiment ce
que c'est d'ailleurs quand je dis le
microbiote je devrais dire le microbiote
intestinal parce que que des microbiotes
on en a plusieurs sur la peau dans la
bouche dans le vagin pour les personnes
qu'en possèd un et puis donc dans les
intestins tant qu'on y est on dit les
intestin parce qu'on en a deux
l'intestin grê qui est juste là à la
sortie de l'estomac et le colon juste
après et donc làdedans c'est plein de
bactéries mais pas seulement il y a
aussi des virus des champignons et puis
d'autres trucs comme les arqués ou les
protistes qu'on connaît moins mais qui
sont importants aussi bon mais on va
appeler tout ça des microbes et retenir
que c'est ce qui constitue le microbiote
intestinal ces microbes ont en a 100000
milliards dans les intestins c'est
énorme c'est beaucoup plus que nos
propres cellules mais vous inquiétez pas
ils ont la place ils ont 400 m carré de
surface habitable ça fait un joli petit
loft bref vous avez compris le
microbiote c'est un vrai truc c'est même
parfois considéré comme un organe à part
entière donc ça pèse dans le game ça
pèse littéralement parce que au total
notre microbiote intestinale c'est 2 kg
de microbe c'est-à-dire autant que le
poids de notre peau et plus lourd que
notre cœur qui pèse à peu près 300 g ou
que notre cerveau qui atteint
péniblement 1 K5 et encore pas chez tout
le monde mais je veux pas donner de N
alors je sais je sais ce que vous allez
me demander mais à quoi ça sert le
microbiote déjà faut rétablir la vérité
le microbiote c'est ces 100000 milliards
de microbes qu'on a là dans les
intestins ça peut faire peur bah oui les
microbes on nous a appris à nous en
méfier surtout ceux qu'on a dans ce coin
là ensuite on nous a dit qu'il y en
avait des bons et des mauvais en fait
c'est pas vraiment comme ça que ça se
passe le même microbe il peut être bon
s'il est au bon roit et mauvais s'il est
au mauvais endroit une bactérie quand
elle est dans le colon elle peut aider à
la digestion par exemple mais la même
bactérie dans la VCI ça donne une
infection urinaire par contre si tout le
monde reste à sa place tout va bien le
microbiote intestinal c'est un peu comme
une société une communauté dans laquelle
tout le monde a sa place et une
entreprise dans laquelle chacun a son
rôle avec un objectif commun notre santé
et oui parce que notre microbiote
intestinale il ne nous sert pas qu'à
fabriquer du caca il a plusieurs rôles
très pointus dans le domaine de la
digestion bien sûr et c'est déjà pas mal
mais pas seulement il joue aussi un rôle
important au niveau de notre système
immunitaire il nous protège contre un
certain nombre de maladies qui ont rien
à voir avec nos intestins au premier
abord et il est même capable de
communiquer avec notre cerveau et
d'influencer notre comportement chaque
individu a un microbiote unique si on se
monraine au microbiotes le mien serait
pas tout à fait le même que le vôtre moi
par exemple je digère mal les oignons
oui bon c'est pas le sujet mais en tout
cas votre microbiote il est unique et il
y a plusieurs raisons à ça d'abord parce
que vous en héritez en partie de votre
mère au moment de la naissance on est en
contact avec le microbiote vaginal et le
microbiote intestinal de notre maman je
vous sépare une mes images mais vous
avez l'idée les microbes de notre mère
ils s'installent en nous et on va les
garder toute notre vie on le sait parce
qu'on a retrouvé des germes maternels
chez des personn âgé mais notre
microbiote c'est pas juste celui de
notre maman on se constitue le nôtre au
fur et à mesure avec une première grosse
étape entre 4 et 6 mois au moment de ce
qu'on appelle la diversification
alimentaire quand on commence à manger
des nouveaux aliments bah ça permet à
des nouveaux microbes d'intégrer la
grande famille et de se développer et
tout ça ça va continuer à évoluer tout
au long de notre vie mais différemment
d'un individu à l'autre en fonction de
l'âge et du sexe mais surtout de nos
habitudes de vie de notre alimentation
par exemple qui joue un rôle très
important dans la composition de notre
microbiote intestinale le fait de manger
des fruits et des légumes ça peut
changer les choses du tout au tout mais
aussi le fait de fumer ou pas qui fait
qu'au bout du compte vu le nombre de
combinaisons possibles entre les
centaines d'espèces de microbes qui
peuvent faire partie de notre microbiote
ou pas dans des proportions différentes
notre microbiote il est unique mais
alors du coup notre microbiote c'est un
peu comme nos empreintes digitales non
on dirait quand
[Musique]
même
procédons au relevé d'empreinte
microbiotal et ben non parce que notre
microbiote certes il est unique mais il
change tout le temps vous prenez des
antibiotiques selon la molécule ça tue
certaines bactéries donc ça modifie voir
ça déséquilibre votre microbiote on
appelle ça une dysbiose et ça a des
conséquences en a certaines je suis sûr
que vous les avez
remarquéout vous changez d'alimentation
et de niveau d'hygiène pendant un voyage
par exemple modifie aussi et là encore
je suis sûr que vous voyez de quoi je
veux parler mais il y a encore plus fort
on se transmet nos microbiotes entre
nous il y a un peu de vos partenair de
vos amis de de vos proches de vos
coloques de vos enfants de vos parents
en vous il vit en toi et évidemment plus
les contacts sont rapprochés et
prolongés plus la transmission est
importante oui bon mais et ces super
pouvoirs alors j'y viens super pouvoir
numéro 1 notre microbiote intestinale
c'est de la potion magique notre
microbiote c'est une source d'énergie
incroyable et on est tombé dedans quand
on était petit tous ces microbes ils
jouent un rôle particulier dans la
digestion bien sûr et c'est pas parce
que ça se passe dans les intestins que
c'est juste de la gestion de déchet il y
a certains aliments qui ne peuvent pas
être correctement assimilés sans eux les
germes qui composent notre microbiote
ils sont capables de transformer ce qui
arrive jusqu'à eux en nutriment en
énergie et de synthétiser des vitamines
en gros il rentabilise au maximum tout
ce qui est avalé et qui n'a pas encore
été digérer et ça c'est une source
d'énergie qui est très loin d'être
négligeable chez les animaux par exemple
on sait que ceux qui ont été privés de
microbiotes ont des besoins énergétiques
de 20 à 30 % supérieur aux autres c'est
quand même pas mal super pouvoir numéro
2 notre microbiote contrôle notre
appétit on estime aujourd'hui qu'un
microbiote équilibré ça nous permet de
ressentir plus facilement la satiété
c'est-à-dire le fait de ne plus avoir
faim et ça nous pousse à manger plus
équilibré les microbes de nos intestins
ils sont capables de réguler notre prise
alimentaire en fonction de la qualité
des aliments qu'on avale et quand on
sait que la qualité de notre microbiote
intestinale elle dépend énormément de la
qualité de ce qu'on mange on se dit que
c'est soit un cercle vertueux soit un
cercle vicieux selon le cas dans lequel
on est il y a aussi des études qui ont
permis de mettre en lien des
déséquilibres du microbiote intestinal
et l'obésité ou l'anorexie mentale mais
comment ils font tout ça les microbes là
le
quoi et ben ils font tout ça grâce à
leur super pouvoir numéro 3 notre
microbiote intestinale contrôle notre
cerveau vous avez déjà entendu dire que
nos intestins c'est notre deuxième
cerveau bon c'est un petit effet de
style pour intéresser les gens le prenez
pas au pied de la lettre on réfléchit
pas avec nos intestins encore que il y
en a on se demande mais ce qui est sûr
c'est que nos intestins ils ont une
relation étroite avec notre cerveau
grâce au système nerveux mais aussi
grâce au microbiotes on sait par exemple
qu'il y a un air qui permet au
microbiotes d'établir une communication
directe avec le cerveau ce nerf c'est le
nerf VAG c'est un nerf crânien donc il
est relié au cerveau c'est celui qui est
le plus long et il a des interactions
avec le cœur les poumons et donc les
intestins le ner vague il fait plein de
trucs comme nous provoquer des malaises
un malaise vagal ça vous dit quelque
chose et ben on sait maintenant que ce
nerf VAG il est capable de réguler notre
humeur mais aussi l'anxiété et les états
dépressifs les chercheurs estime que
tout ça ça se fait grâce à certains
types de bactéries quand tu en as pas
assez ça se dégrade et à l'inverse quand
augmente ça va mieux donc vu qu'on se
refile nos microbes entre nous et qui
sont capables de contrôler notre cerveau
et d'influencer notre comportement
est-ce qu'on peut dire qu'on se manipule
les uns les autres par intestin
interposé ou alors carrément que les
micro-organismes de nos microbiotes ils
ont un plan secret pour tous nous
contrôler et devenir les maîtres du
monde non
ah dommage j'aimais bien l'idée bon
super pouvoir numéro 4 notre microbiote
peut nous guérir donc le microbiote joue
un rôle dans la dépression c'est
évidemment pas le seul facteur mais ça
entre en jeu mais c'est pas tout
certaines études suggèrent aussi qu'il a
un lien avec la schizophrénie et les
troubles bipolaires et c'est pas encore
tout vu que le microbiote intestinal il
a aussi une influence sur le système
nerveux et sur le cerveau on a déterminé
qu'il avait des conséquences sur les
troubles du développement
neurocomportemental comme les troubles
de la sphère autistique par exemple mais
aussi dans l'apparition de certaines
maladies du système nerveux comme
Alzheimer ou la sclérose en plaque ou
d'autres maladies liées à notre
métabolisme on estime par exemple que un
déséquilibre du microbiote intestinal ça
peut entraîner la multiplication d'une
molécule le propionate d'imidazo dans
l'organisme et cette molécule elle a la
particularité de provoquer des
résistances à l'insuline qui est une
substance sécrété par notre pancréas qui
nous permet de réguler notre taux de
sucre conséquence directe ça fait aussi
augmenter le risque d'une certaine forme
de diabète qu'on appelle le diabète de
type 2 on peut aussi citer les maladies
inflammatoires de l'intestin évidemment
mais aussi des allergies des cancers
certaines maladies cardio-vasculaires
notre microbiote il a une influence sur
des choses aussi variées que des
troubles du développement des maladies
psy des maladies autoimmunes et cetera
et cetera donc ok ça veut dire que quand
il se déséquilibre bah ça peut entraîner
des problèmes mais surtout si on regarde
les choses d'un autre angle ça veut dire
que si on arrive à bien l'équilibrer ou
à bien le rééquilibrer ça va nous
permettre de les éviter ces problèmes
alors on a déjà développé un certain
nombre de techniques comme la greffe de
caca par exemple on dit transplantation
du microbiote fécal c'est plus chic on
en reparlera de ces jours mais à
l'avenir on va mettre au point de plus
en plus de traitement pour améliorer
notre microbiote intestinale et lui
permettre de jouer son rôle à fond
c'est-à-dire lui permettre de nous
maintenir en bonne santé et de nous
éviter un certain nombre de troubles et
de maladies super pouvoir numéro 5 notre
microbiote nous protège et ouais c'est
quelque chose qu'on sait pas forcément
mais notre microbiote intestinal il joue
un rôle important dans le développement
et la régulation de notre système
immunitire et ça commence très tôt ça
commence au moment de la diversification
alimentaire dont je vous ai parlé tout à
l'heure elle va avoir non seulement une
influence sur notre microbiote mais elle
va aussi déclencher une grosse réaction
immunitaire en rapport avec ces trucs
nouveaux là qu'on introduit dans notre
organisme à ce moment-là notre système
immunitaire il va se mettre en ordre de
bataille et les microbes qui vivent dans
nos intestins ils vont apprendre à
travailler avec les cellules de notre
système immunitaire et ils vont même les
aider à apprendre à fonctionner et à
apprendre à connaître les germes
potentiellement dangereux cette
collaboration elle va se prolonger tout
au long de notre vie et nos microbes ils
vont travailler main dans la main avec
nos cellules immunitaire parfois en les
stimulant parfois en mettant eux-mêmes
la main à la patte tout ça évidemment à
la même condition que pour tous les
autres super pouvoir que l'équilibre
soit respecté
sinon notre microbiote intestinale il
est capable de faire plein d'autres
trucs encore d'ailleurs au moment où
cette vidéo est sortie j'étais en train
d'animer une conférence à l'Institut
Pasteur avec avec un chercheur
spécialisé dans les liens entre le
microbiote intestinal et l'immunité je
vous mets le lien dans la description de
la vidéo dès que le Replay est
disponible vous irez regarder ça si vous
voulez en apprendre plus là-dessus voilà
DTC c'est fini pour aujourd'hui on se
retrouve très vite pour de nouvelles
vidéos d'ici là prenez soin de vous
prenez soin de votre microbiote
intestinale prenez soin des autres
mettez-vous bien et surtout portez-vous
bien